now the next time you hear democrats
claim that republicans or pro-second
amendment types don't care about
children or their safety
i want you to do one thing i want you to
laugh in their faces
because they're the ones who don't care
about the kids
their policies help create the fertile
ground from which some of the most the
nation's most violent figures have
emerged
now of course they ignore any of the
cultural and societal issues simmering
beneath the surface and instead accuse
conservatives of refusing to compromise
on guns
well very quickly
maybe more folks would be willing to
compromise on guns if democrats
themselves
hadn't told us what their real goal
really is
i just took the position that may not be
politically popular maybe too honest
that not only should no one be able to
purchase an ar-15 i don't think that the
people who have them right now in
civilian use should be able to keep them
we need a moratorium perhaps on gun
sales
we need to who will say on this network
or any other network in the next few
days it's time to repeal the second
amendment
and as usual when joe biden shoots his
mouth off he's reaches he reaches new
heights of idiocy
a nine millimeter bullet
blows the lung out of the body
so the idea of these
high caliber
weapons
is there's simply no rational basis for
it in terms of
about
self-protection hunting
i mean i just i remember
the constitution the second amendment
was never absolute
you couldn't buy a cannon
when the second amendment was back
well i guess we have to add the line
ballistics expert to joe's resume
does he even know by the way what the
number nine refers to or the letters m
for that matter i'm not quite so sure
now the fact is most democrats on tv
they
lately appearing the only opine about
dead children when there are political
points to be scored
remember last year was the most deadly
in a quarter century in chicago nearly
800 killed
so where were the protests or the
rallies
where was beto or biden
the victims have often been young
rarely acknowledged and quickly
forgotten
in january eight-year-old melissa ortega
shot in chicago by gangbanger stray
bullets
in february 15 year old sincere cole was
shot 24 times just around the block from
his home earlier this month a 16 year
old boy was shot and killed near the
bean
a popular tourist attraction
and over memorial day weekend there was
sadly the typical carnage in chicago
with 51 shot and nine dead
the most violent weekend since 2017
and in baltimore
four dead including a 17 year old named
neil mack
now the angle has actually done two
major town halls in chicago examining
the violent crime that's plagued the
residents there for years
and we asked mayor lori lightfoot to
appear with us in front of a live
audience they're all of her constituents
after all well she never agreed
we found out a lot though
we need to stop waiting to hit our
doorstep
we need to say something if we see
something i've been here for over 50
some years i raised my kids here i am
scared
we need to stick together we need to
speak out
you know silence is just the worst thing
ever
these are our kids
and they are important to us
her mother
that was the mother of the young man who
was burned alive in a barrel
but nothing did change in fact things
only got worse and left-wing politicians
continue to support policies that made
life more dangerous for our young
things like covet lockdowns from schools
to rec centers
that's all on the teachers unions they
dropped a match on a powder keg
of course only now our media outlets
finally admitting how damaging those
closures were for children
then there was the tolerance and even
celebration of criminal behavior during
the summer of love summer 2020.
that created a justified atmosphere of
rage and rampage
i say hey nobody said that protest has
to be peaceful by meaning that passive
and tranquil people should be angry they
should voice they should blame they
should shame that's all allowed in
america even if it makes people
uncomfortable
the left has been on a 50-year mission
really to de-emphasize the importance of
fathers in the home and the results have
been disastrous for all americans
especially for young men in urban
settings
we've always had kind of a private
notion of children your kid is yours and
totally your responsibility we haven't
had a very collective notion of these
are our children we have to break
through our kind of private idea that
kids belong to their parents or kids
belong to their families and recognize
that kids belong to whole communities
of course salvador ramos was another
mass shooter who was the product of a
broken home
no dad on the scene
mom lives with boyfriend mom's a user
police even shows up at the show up at
the house during aggressive fighting
between him and his mother
like so many isolated young men
i guess perhaps he what looks for
belonging and safety and maybe a new
identity changes his looks wears all
black spends hours in chat rooms online
with strangers
cuts himself on his face all over his
face for fun
he drops out of school
yet no one seemed to step in no one
the only one who maybe tried he ended up
shooting in the face
his grandmother
a stable home for children run by adults
who hold themselves and the kids
accountable
is of paramount importance
a dysfunctional home life where drugs
are easily accessible puts too many
young people on a highway to hell these
days
and speaking of drugs according to the
daily mail well the new york times had
originally reported that ramos smoked
pot then mysteriously the reference was
missing from the online editions
now why is that
was it bad information
or is this the pro-marijuana bias that
we've become accustomed to that's so
powerful because billions are on the
line with it nationwide
so is the story now irrelevant
we reached out to the times on this
but they have not responded
now the american people are hearing a
lot about ar-15s and background checks
but they also deserve to hear about this
as well
respected medical studies for years now
have demonstrated that pot use
especially among teens can trigger
psychosis and increase the chance that a
young person will develop violent
behaviors
the association of mature american
citizens right
a 2017 study identified marijuana as the
single most common correlative variable
in otherwise diverse populations and
circumstances surrounding the
association of violence and marijuana
reported links exist to shooters in
parkland el paso dayton aurora colorado
tucson chattanooga sacramento and
perhaps elsewhere
now a friend of the dayton shooter conor
betts told authorities that he was a gun
owner and that he had done hard drugs
with bets as well as marijuana and acid
four or five times a week from 2014 to
2015.
former new york times reporter alex
berenson has written extensively on this
subject
a 2012 paper in the journal of
interpersonal violence examining a
federal survey of more than 9 000
adolescents
found that marijuana use was associated
with a doubling of domestic violence in
the u.s
then there's this the national library
of medicine recent illicit and medical
marijuana is of much higher potency and
more likely to cause violent behavior
high potency marijuana is a predictable
and preventable cause of tragic violent
consequences
my question tonight is
why isn't there a national conversation
happening right now about this
why aren't reporters doing more to
demand information on the
potential drug use in this case and
others
both illicit drugs and prescription
drugs
antidepressants have long been known to
be a problem for some young people
or are we all just going to pretend that
joe confiscating all the nine
millimeters or beto running a gun
buyback program is going to heal and
protect our youth is that what we're
hoping
you see i'd rather operate in the real
world
and that world is a lot more complicated
than the anti-second amendment anti-gun
activists would suggest
whenever there is a societal cultural
familial and spiritual deficit
bad things are going to rush in to fill
it
guns gangs drugs then there will be harm
to others or self-harm
and until we're honest about all of this
young people will continue to be pawns
in a political game and that's the angle
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else